never too old to chase a dream yeah 37  year old mother of two has become the  fastest american woman to run a marathon  listen to her reaction this is cool  this dream was gone a decade ago and  somehow  i just believed that you know age is  just number and it just doesn't even  matter how old you are  it does not matter how old you are keira  d'amato who won the houston marathon in  two hours 19 minutes and 12 seconds  breaking the previous american record by  24 seconds guys she took seven years off  from running to get married to have kids  her son tommy greeted her at the end of  sunday's race watches oh i love this  kind of like mom's famous and it's cool  to have a famous mother  is crazy you can like watch the kids  watch a movie while you run a marathon  yes i love the message she was saying  right two young kids two young kids  started from the bottom now she's here  oh there we go